[Musica]
quando Da bambino giocavo a calcio per
le strade della mia città avevo la mania
di osservare la costante crescita dei
nuovi edifici che in quegli anni si
innalzavano erano gli anni del
cosiddetto Boom edilizio e i nuovi
condomini venivano realizzati spesso
solo per speculare Senza un minimo di
progettazione buon gusto e assenza di
analisi del territorio nonostante siamo
riconosciuti in tutto il mondo come il
bel paese e nonostante noi italiani
abbiamo realizzato nel corso dei secoli
opere di ingegneria e opere di
architettura che ancora oggi tutto il
mondo ci invidia
per rendervi ancora più chiaro questo
concetto ho deciso di portarvi
un'immagine
ecco cos'è che non va in questo modello
se osservate bene questo edificio
diventa un po' la metafora degli ultimi
50 anni consuma spreca ed inquina senza
che nessuno importi nulla io sono certo
che se ora vi chiedessi cosa c'entrano i
nostri condomini e quindi le nostre case
con l'innalzamento delle temperature e
con i cambiamenti climatici forse pochi
di voi riuscirebbero a dare la risposta
corretta quando acquistiamo una casa o
magari quando la viviamo ci concentriamo
solo su aspetti di tipo estetico come ad
esempio il colore dei pavimenti la
tipologia di arredo o magari la
tipologia delle porte pensando
erroneamente che i cambiamenti climatici
siano qualcosa che sia al di fuori dalle
nostre case
Eppure trascorriamo il 90 per cento del
nostro tempo all'interno di edifici come
ad esempio le nostre case i nostri
uffici o magari l'azienda dentro la
quale lavoriamo senza però capire
realmente come questi funzionino e
quindi quanto consumano cosa consumano
Ma soprattutto quanto siano connessi
alle nostre vite visto che il tema di
oggi è appunto connessioni
per rendervi ancora più chiaro questo
concetto partiamo da qui le nostre case
producono CO2 quando pensiamo alla
famosa parola CO2 il gas responsabile
dell'innalzamento delle temperature il
nostro pensiero va tendenzialmente alle
automobili eppure i veicoli a motore
sono responsabili di circa il 10% delle
emissioni di CO2 quando pensiamo invece
al patrimonio immobiliare italiano
questo è responsabile pensate del 40%
delle missioni di CO2
e non è tutto Gli edifici sono i più
grandi divoratori di nuovo solo in
Italia disponiamo di un patrimonio
immobiliare di centinaia di chilometri
quadrati costituito da edifici non più
in uso e fatiscenti una superficie che
supera anche la dimensione della città
di Milano e la cittadinapoli messi
insieme Eppure si continua a costruire
sul nuovo solo quando potremo andare a
recuperare tutto questo patrimonio
immobiliare esistente non più in uso
andando a rigenerare e Dare nuova vita
ad interi quartieri di città
abbiamo parlato di area ovviamente
dobbiamo parlare anche di acqua le
nostre case sprecano troppa acqua
potabile in Italia sprechiamo
all'incirca il 13% di acqua potabile per
usi civili questo è dovuto al fatto che
abbiamo una cattiva consuetudine di
impiegarla per tutti gli impieghi anche
dove Questa non è necessaria come ad
esempio tirare l'acqua in bagno lavare i
nostri pavimenti e ricari i nostri
Giardini quando poi la cosa paradossale
è che le piante in natura si irrigano
con l'acqua della pioggia e non di certo
con l'acqua potabile
[Applauso]
arrivati a questo punto ho deciso di
portarvi l'immagine di un prototipo di
un edificio che prova a rispettare di
più l'ambiente ma soprattutto di più le
nostre vite per farlo vorrei in pochi
secondi rappresentarvelo utilizzando i
quattro elementi base che troviamo in
natura Partiamo dalla terra e quindi dal
suolo dove dovrà appoggiare le proprie
fondamenta per essere un intervento
ritenuto sostenibile dovrà essere dovrà
nascere su terreni su soli già edificati
in precedenza e quindi dovrà essere
frutto di un intervento di rigenerazione
urbana che prevede la demolizione e la
ricostruzione dell'edificio preesistente
e eventualmente una ricostruzione
radicale costruire ex novo su terreni
non edificati in precedenza significa ad
andare ad impermeabilizzare ulteriore
terreno la cosiddetta cementificazione
del suolo questo comporta l'acqua della
pioggia quando cade sul terreno di
trovare un terreno impermeabile e quindi
non a penetrare nel sottosuolo andando a
ricaricare le falde acquifere aumentando
ovviamente il rischio idrogeologico del
territorio per di più l'acqua della
pioggia Una volta caduto su questo
terreno impermeabile andrà a finire nel
nostro sistema fognario nella rete
fognaria Aumentando il carico dell'acqua
e quindi durante le giornate di forte
pioggia Aumentando il rischio di
allagamenti
e questo l'ambiente non ce lo perdona
più
parliamo di area per fare una doccia
calda per riscaldare il nostro
appartamento o magari per cucinare un
buon piatto necessitiamo di gas la
principale fonte di energia fossile
impiegata negli edifici Ma anche la
responsabile di quel 40% di cui vi
parlavo prima l'alternativa sostenibile
quale potrebbe essere sicuramente non
quella di spegnere tutto ma impiegare
come il prototipo che ho portato fonti
di energia rinnovabile che vanno a
sostituire le fonti di energia fossile
in questo caso energia solare che riesce
a produrre energia sul posto e quindi
non come nel caso del gas acquistare
energia migliaia di chilometri di
distanza dal nostro paese e per di più
energia pulita parliamo di acqua prima
vi ho parlato di acqua piovana acqua
potabile e sicuramente saprete che
l'emergenza siccità è sempre più diffusa
diventa quindi impensabile
utilizzare l'acqua potabile per tutti
gli impieghi anche Questa non è
necessaria un'alternativa che ho portato
per il mio prototipo è quella di
utilizzare una tecnologia alquanto
banale pensate già veniva impiegata
dagli antichi romani Ovvero quella di
installare delle vasche di accumulo che
riescono a recuperare l'acqua piovana
durante quindi le piogge e riutilizzarla
a seguito di trattamenti per tutti gli
impieghi dove non è necessario l'impiego
dell'acqua potabile
infine l'ultimo elemento che troviamo in
natura il fuoco sicuramente anche qui
saprete che le nostre città stanno
diventando sempre più calde le
cosiddette isole di calore e Se pensate
durante le giornate di caldo le nostre
case si comportano un po' come le
automobili quanto più fuori fa caldo
tanto più all'interno Si riscaldano
questo è dovuto al fatto che assorbono
sempre più calore che poi fatica a
riuscire per via Della Bassa
traspirabilità dell'involucro esterno
quindi dobbiamo ricorrere continuamente
ai sistemi di aria condizionata
aumentando Di conseguenza anche i
consumi energetici un'alternativa
potrebbe essere quella di impiegare
sistemi materiali e tecnologie più
performanti ed innovative materiali che
non deteriorano con facilità e quindi
vadano a ridurre gli interventi
manutentivi dei nostri condomini
riducendo anche i consumi sia energetici
che di materiale ma soprattutto
materiali che troviamo in natura e che
riescano a godere di alto grado di
traspirabilità In modo tale da garantire
una respirazione naturale per le nostre
abitazioni anche quando abbiamo le
finestre chiuse in modo tale che durante
le giornate di freddo riescono a Non
disperdere il calore prodotto e di
conseguenza ridurre l'Impiego di sistemi
di riscaldamento mentre durante il
periodo estivo riescono a ridurre
l'assorbimento di calore e riescono a
far respirare la casa anche avendo i
nostri infissi chiusi infine tetti Verdi
tetti giardino cioè dei tetti con della
vegetazione sulle nostre coperture che
riescono ad assorbire l'acqua piovana
durante le giornate di pioggia in modo
da ridurre il sovraccarico dell'acqua
nella nostra nel nostro sistema fognario
e ridurre anche il pericolo di
allagamento ma soprattutto tetti verdi
che si comportano come sistemi di aria
condizionata per le nostre abitazioni
per concludere vorrei che questa sera
tornassimo a casa e pensassimo a quante
delle cose dette oggi possiamo mettere
in pratica un sistema abitativo migliore
c'è come ad esempio quello che oggi vi
ho portato ma è necessario raggiungere
la consapevolezza e soprattutto
diffonderla dell'impatto che hanno le
nostre abitazioni sull'ambiente e quindi
acquistare e costruire case sempre più
rispettose dell'ambiente ma soprattutto
delle nostre vite Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]